[Musique]
depuis 2018 le journaliste et ancien
ministre de l'écologie nicolas hulot est
visé par une plainte d'agression
sexuelle nicolas hulot cola hulot
nicolas hulot se diviser par des
accusations de viol et d'agressions
sexuelles une plainte qui remonterait en
réalité à l'effet qu'il se serait passé
en 1992 un mouvement féministe avait
alors perturber une conférence de presse
qu'il donnait en septembre dernier pour
accuser nicolas hulot ça a été jugé par
la justice la justice a parlé ce soir un
reportage exclusif d'envoyé spécial est
diffusée sur france 2 une enquête choc
qui révélait les témoignages de cinq
nouvelles victimes ce soir enquête sur
nicolas hulot des femmes accusent
la sortie de ce reportage nicolas hulot
a décidé de s'exprimer hier matin sur le
plateau de bruce toussaint ni de près ni
de loin je n'ai commis ces actes ces
affirmations sont purement manche en jeu
au cours de l'interview il dément
fermement les accusations sans même en
connaître le contenu selon les
accusations pour le moment son nom et
dont j'ignore tout alors affaire de viol
nicolas hulot at il bien fait de
s'exprimer avant les révélations
merci fatima v noirs d'être avec nous
merci d'être là fatima qui vient souvent
nous voir chronique sur rmc et féminisme
bien entendu et vous êtes chez sitel
denis aussi c'est vrai que bfm a donné
la parole à nicolas hulot on va voir les
premiers extraits de cette interview
c'était à 11h03
11h03 ont déjà fait tout un nra dérouler
les internautes 15h03 il est innocent
mais ne peut pas dormir tranquille c'est
ce que dit nicolas hulot regardez j'ai
appris par cette émission
d'investigation
que à l'issue selon leurs propres mots
d'une enquête de quatre ans
il aurait obtenu
je dirais peut-être même arraché des
témoignages qui me met gravement en
cause et l'expérience que je vais livrer
aujourd'hui montre que dans le monde
dans lequel on vit
être innocent ne permet plus de dormir
tranquille
pis alors fatima marque envoyé ce
premier extrait vous réagissez comme ans
ben nous on a été content on contacte
plutôt avec des femmes qui n'arrivait
pas à dormir tranquille depuis des
années et en plus en général il est
story si cette histoire à partir de 2018
quand le scandale a éclaté pour une
première fois alors qu'ils avaient déjà
en fait des traces écrites qui était qui
circulaient par exemple bérengère bonté
qui était la biographe de nicolas hulot
qui écrit dans son livre saint nicolas
que quand elle faisait son portrait les
personnes qui l interrogeait disait
toujours bon il faudra à un moment aussi
parlé dans son rapport aux femmes et il
parlait de ces jeunes stagiaires ses
collaboratrices des personnes qui
n'avaient pas beaucoup de pouvoir autour
de lui qui se plaignait de son
comportement elle raconte en 2018 en
conférence que quand elle avait
interviewé donc un patron d'aj ans où il
y avait une jeune photographe stagiaires
inexpérimenté dont hulot selon ce
témoignage voulait absolument qu'elles
viennent il était venu ici c'est jean
michel aphatie qui lui avait raconté
aussi jean michel aphatie par ailleurs
ces langues et des journalistes les plus
exemplaires sur cette histoire qui est
vraiment disait on parle d'un cri même
s'il ya eu qu'un seul vial on ne peut
pas balayer cette histoire du revers de
la main comme ça a été fait
en 2018 et c'est vrai que soul ludo pin
dans dans cette émission il dit mais
pourquoi elle parle après la
prescription alors il nie les faits à
11h06 regarder mais je veux dire et sans
effet de manche sans formule
sans éléments de langage et sans
fioritures
ni de près ni de loin
je n'ai commis ces actes
ils sont ces affirmations sont purement
mensongère je le dis ici une fois pour
toutes fermement
et définitivement
alors c'est la deuxième fois donc ils
adoptent des stratégies c'est ça
s'appelle des mines et c'est à dire qui
va avant la sortie en 2018 de
révélations dans feue l'hebdomadaire
hebdo qui n'avait pas duré il va chez
jean jacques bourdin et là il va chez
bruce tout ça pour dire je n'ai rien
commis alors c'est une stratégie qui a
des effets pervers parce que du coup
tout le monde porte attention à ce qui
va se passer déminage ne fonctionne pas
tellement puisque tout le monde en parle
aujourd'hui et donc il ya cinq
témoignages quatre rondes enquête cinq
témoignages très précis alors il n'y a
pas d'affaires judiciaires à notre
connaissance on a enquêté il ya une
plainte en 2008 contre lui c'est tout
mais là il s'agit pas de ça sont des
témoignages pour des faits prescrits
mais c'est vrai que ça va faire grand
bruit ce soir oui mais en même temps il
avait pas énormément le choix parce que
élise lucet la plaie en direct
avant-hier en lui disant voilà venez
témoigner et il a dit fait qui manquent
qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans l'émission
denis ça je peux pas vous le dire je dis
bah si je peux donner il appelait
delphine ernotte en disant attention
vous savez ce que vous risquez j'espère
que voilà vaguement un peu un peu
menaçant ce que je peux comprendre et
donc du coup il l'a choisi c'est lui
même qui c'est qui s'est présentée qui a
décidé de parler d'environnement tout le
monde l'aurait accueilli pour le faire
mais alors est-ce qu'il n'avait pas trop
le choix de parler en revanche il a été
maladroit dans sa communication ça c'est
clair le direct leurs noms mais je
trouve ça quand même assez choquant
parce qu en déminant quelques paris
confie ce que la parole des présumées
victimes et quelque part dès le départ
il est trés de menteuse donc quelque
part on va regarder ce reportage en
disant bon elles ont menti a finalement
à la lumière de ce qu'a dit nicolas
hulot et je trouve que c'est un tout
petit peu déplacé finalement le réduire
est en direct c'est ce soir d'accord
pourrait
facilement vous est-ce que vous avez
déjà vous aviez déjà eu vent de 2
comporte
déplacé de la part de nicolas hulot pas
du tout oui le livre dont je parle est
publié en 2010 et effectivement quand
j'étais reçu dans les médias en 2018
faut déjà savoir qu'il y avait une
petite ambiance qui était vraiment en
solidarité plutôt avec nicolas hulot je
me suis retrouvé un moment sur bfm avec
un journaliste qui me dit je suis
choquée parce que du fait de la peine
parce que pour moi il n'y a pas
d'affaires hulot c'est à dire que ce
n'était même pas possible que ce soit en
discussion et puis quand il dit
oui mais pourquoi elles ont attendu pour
parler déjà parce que là il y a un
instant un peu plus favorable à la
parole on est en pleine nuit tout
politique et puis ces femmes elles ont
eu peur pendant longtemps parce qu'ils
avaient des antécédents
par exemple quand on s'attaque à des
hommes puissants tristane banon quand
elle avait essayé de faire son
témoignage contre des escales sont été
pris plein la gueule et puis quand ces
femmes avaient commencé à se dire tiens
on va parler de nicolas hulot tout le
gouvernement parce que maintenant madame
morano elle prend un petit peu ses
distances maintenant que nicolas hulot
n'est plus au gouvernement mais à
l'époque en avait deux pour une langue
la république
emmanuel macron kidian nicolas il faut
que tu tiennes contre ces accusations on
avait eu madame schepp a quand même qui
était là ministre droits des femmes la
scala marlène schiappa aujourd'hui voilà
mais la verra aussi bien d'autres en
disant que c'était une manipulation
konitz et
devenir assez virulent persie que madame
mori no 1 elisabeth voilà que le
gouvernement avait fait bloc et imaginer
ses victimes qui voit le président hans
leur premier ministre leur ministre aux
droits des femmes dire même pas dire on
ne se positionne pas les faire mentir
faire mentir ces femmes là en disant
mais non c'est un homme charmant mal etc
on le croit et tout donc c'est pour ça
qu'il a fallu ces quatre années
d'investigation et je suis heureuse que
ce soit un journal de qualité quand même
que comme envoyé spécial qui a fait une
haie une enquête sérieuse qui a pris son
temps et qui a attendu le rythme des
victimes parce que ce qu'on aurait pu
reprocher à hebdo ceux qui voulaient
aller plus vite que les victimes ça
c'est très frustrant quand on est des
militantes on a des témoignages on peut
pas les sortir parce qu'aussi d'une
énorme violence de sortir les la parole
avant de ces femmes avant de la voir
qu'elles soient prêtes et la maintenance
et le moment est donc aujourd'hui on va
enfin pouvoir entendre leurs pâles or
nicolas hulot regardez ce qui lie sur
sur ces femmes qui l'accusent pourquoi
ces femmes se prend-elle la parole pour
vous accusez mais posez leur la question
je n'en sais rien farm bruce tout ça je
ne sais même pas de qui il s'agit je ne
sais même pas comment l'expliquez vous
cp non mais je ne les explique pas
est-ce que vous avez eues dans le passé
durant votre vie un comportement en
général j'ai avec les juges je viens
aujourd'hui susciter ces plaintes ou ses
yeux accusations ni de parler ni de loin
ni de près ni de loin
s'il dit ne pas connaître ces femmes un
nikolay louisville alors ce qu'on attend
de savoir le secret très bien gardé mais
c'est si parmi ces cinq femmes deux ont
déjà été identifiés on a parlé
d'affaires autour de nicolas hulot donc
voilà il ya j'ai même pas dire qu'il est
présumé innocent puisque a pas d'action
judiciaire mais on a parlé d'affaires de
la fille d'une ancienne ministre du
gouvernement jospin
et d'une employée de l'ambassade de
france à moscou ou qui auraient été
agressées sexuellement ces deux femmes
là on les connaît reste à savoir si
elles sont dans les cinq ou six se
seraient cinq nouveaux témoignages pour
le moment personne ne sait dans la
stratégie de communication ce qui est
assez earth en moi je trouve c'est que
en gros il explique que parce que
effectivement la question de bruce est
vraiment très pertinente pourquoi cinq
femmes viendraient de 1 matin ce serait
dire on a subi une agression voire un
viol et bien lui et sous ton tout le
temps dans toute l'interview qu'en fait
il y aurait sorte de cabale et qu'en
fait en gros il dit celles qui sont à la
manoeuvre sous-entendu derrière ces cinq
femmes se cacherait un groupuscule de
femmes qui voient là où une manoeuvre
politique ou quelque chose qui vient
tendresse et je trouve que c'est ça
discrédite pas passé terrible qu'on va
regarder sur la vie de bruce toussaint
il lui rappelle qu'il est connu comme un
don juan regarde savez ce qu'on dit de
vous nicolas hulot pardonnez moi de vous
dire comme ça aussi brutalement un bon
joueur un homme à femmes à baton juin
un homme qui multiplie les conquêtes de
alors je laisse à l'appréciation de ce
qui fait partie des rumeurs sur lequel
on a construit évidemment une histoire
un personnage alors charmeur séducteur
dont joue en dragueur harceleur violeur
et pourquoi pas hein et pourquoi pas et
pourquoi pas où sont les preuves
alors
oui moi je suis désolé je suis personne
pour juger les affaires je ne suis pas
juge mais je trouve que la stratégie de
communication nicolas hulot et les
bonnes à l'heure où on se fait accuser
publiquement dans le criminel médiatique
on a le droit de se mêler prendre qu'1
non mais je suis pas là pour juger pour
lui elle est bonne la nuit là il
intéresse défendre évidemment donc quand
on se fait accuser publiquement on doit
aussi pouvoir se défendre publiquement
et ce timing je le comprends aussi parce
qu'en fait soit il parle jamais pour pas
trop qu'on parle des accusations et
aussi pour laisser la justice faire son
travail
soit ils s'expriment tout de suite on
voit avant les accusations il anticipe
les accusations pas pour les
décrédibiliser mais pour dire voilà je
suis au courant ce qui va sortir les
samoa va me tomber dessus henrique et
assure que les suppléments ya marlène
schiappa qui m'appelle on dirait qu à l
époque dans l'émission donc va
certainement ce qui
bon soir bonsoir marlène schiappa
bonsoir mme
bah oui pavé oui ça va ils vont
alors vous savez qu'on est en émission
je sais que vous saviez qu'on allait
traiter du sujet nicolas hulot ce soir
on avec fatima bruno marc également qui
viennent parler de vous en plus
et c'est vrai en plus voyez vous il
vient de parler de vous vous à petit
j'espère qu'elle va parler de quelqu'un
d'autre
merci marlène schiappa c'est vrai que
est ce que vous voulez vous c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui nicolas hulot fait partie
du gouvernement et fatima disaient terré
que vous avez réagi un moment quand il
était peu réagi quand il était dans le
gouvernement et aujourd'hui vous avez
réagi de façon assez virulente sur les
accusations qui qui qui portait sur lui
alors ma réaction elle est toujours la
même
moi je veux dire plusieurs choses
attention pensée pour toutes les femmes
qui au cours de l'ag ont été victimes de
violences sexuelles que l'allemand
sexuelle à chaque fois qu'on parle de
ces sujets
on a tout ce qui remonte c'est important
de dire ensuite aux premières choses que
j'avais à l'époque c'est qu'elle est pas
vous aviez une femme qui était au
journaliste moi je ne veux pas parler
publiquement du jeune que je devais
avoir vécu que je fais je ne sais pas
comment pas je ne veux pas qu et
articles tilton manquement est pourtant
un journal a décidé contre son gré te
parler c'est ce qu'a dit fatima
c'est exactement ce que va dire fatima
il ya un instant
vécu et aussi compte
d'une chose ce que je dis c'est que on
va voir ce soir quels sont les éléments
qui sont partagés publiquement dans ce
reportage moi je pense que si la
connaissance de crémât le viol est un
crime il faut que la justice s'en
saisissent et ça c'est aussi ce que j'ai
toujours dit ce que j'ai toujours
génération de l'ecoute il est aussi
fondamental qu'on se transforme pas tous
on en tribunes à la
jeunesse est important s'ils ont la
connaissance de jeunes et que la justice
puisse rentrer dans un tribunal marleix
marlène schiappa vous étiez au
gouvernement avec nicolas hulot est ce
que vous avez eu de ses nouvelles depuis
est-ce que vous avez échangé avec lui ou
pas du tout
convaincu consacré voilà vous voilà on
n'était pas du tout contact avec lui
fatima vous avez une question pour omar
la nature mais bon je trouve que ça un
petit peu évasif comme réaction c'est à
dire que ce que vous aviez dit dans
votre tribune guy jdd c'est le viol est
une affaire trop importante pour que ce
soit l'objet d'une instrumentalisation
politique c'est à dire et puis tout le
gouvernement avait fait bloc je me
souviens de sébastien lecornu qui dit je
partage sa douleur à nicolas hulot c'est
un coup qu'il a eue dans le 26/10 le
gouvernement par les japonaises n'est
pas responsable de 400 je pense que ce
serait élégant ce soir de dire que vous
avez eu une mauvaise gestion de cette
affaire je me souviens même qui avait eu
un reportage où on vous montrer en train
de travailler les éléments de l'anp gage
de votre tribune jdd et même où il y
avait des éléments qui était prévu qu'il
pouvait être encore plus dur et très
franchement plutôt que de sarah débat
entre vous et moi et de me dire que
c'était déjà très prudent et bien je
pense que vous pouvez dire que quelques
années sont passées depuis 2018 et
reconnaître que c'est pas comme ça que
vous auriez pu vous auriez dû réagir eu
égard à ces femmes qui ont été heurtés
on a été en contact avec elles et se
sont dit même si j'ai tout le
gouvernement sur le dos je préfère
encore rentré je peux alors marlène
schiappa ce que voulait répondre à
fatima
[Musique]
visé elle disait en résumé marlène que
pau pour elle vous aviez mal géré cette
crise voilà entre guillemets en 2018
exercer des lettres ensemble et elle dit
vous avez reçu deux lettres des victimes
et que voilà aujourd'hui on a besoin de
vous pencher plus sur le dossier qu'en
2018 où vous avez été plus prudentes
oui deux des victimes ont écrit à
l'elysée je sais que ça normal elysées
c'est pas mal et tu as pas l est pas oui
mais ça met à l'abri remous et sam et
créer une discussion entre les ministres
alors
ça m'arrive très régulièrement de
recevoir des lettres
et des mails etc et j'ai une
organisation très stricte avec
l'ensemble de montanay pour justement
que je n'ai aucune intéressant d une
lettre est encore qu'un a connaissance
des viols et violences sexuelles des
violences conjugales je fais saisir la
police et la gendarmerie pour qu'il
puisse avoir une plainte et que les
femmes puissent être protégés je fais
systématiquement quelle que soit
l'identité de la personne mise en cause
c'est arrivé qu'on est en cause des
personnes connues ou des tasseaux du
monde politique je re oriente vers la
police et la gendarmerie pour qu'une
plainte qu'il a déposée et ses leçons de
tout le travail que je mène au ministère
de l'intérieur et si vous permettez je
dis qu'il ya des femmes qui vous
écoutent ville ce soir et qui se disent
qu elles se reconnaissent et qu'elles
ont vécu des choses comme ça elles
peuvent pas déposer plainte soit saisir
la nature arrêtons les violences point
gouv.fr elles peuvent le faire de façon
anonyme
merci marlène schiappa en tout cas nous
avons rappelé en direct c'était pas
prévu je vous dis merci en tout cas
merci beaucoup merci marlène la merci
vous aussi merci voilà donc il ya des
gens qui nous appellent directement
voilà juste une truie convoi cet extrait
qui a fait énormément parler nicolas
hulot qui a ensuite lâché la bombe alors
c'est là bon il annonce se retirer de la
vie publique pour moi ça n'a pas changé
grand chose alors
je vais quitter la présidence d'honneur
de ma fondation qui est l'oeuvre de ma
vie et dans la foulée
et pas plus parce que ma conscience
n'est pas tranquille même si certains
vont l'interpréter comme cela je quitte
définitivement la vie publique tout
simplement parce que je suis écoeuré
qu'est ce que ça signifie concrètement
ça veut dire qu'à partir de maintenant
je vis pour mes amis ma famille
je quitte mon engagement et je vous
exprimerez plus et je ne m'exprimerai
plus messi alors oui fatima là ce qui en
fait la vraie annonce qu'il dit c'est
que il décide de parler avant les
victimes il annonce déjà qu'il ne
parlera pas c'est à dire que in il il
veut que ce qu'on interprète dans le
fait qu'ils ne se défendent pas contre
ce qu'elles vont dire qu'elle sait juste
qu'il a décidé de ne pas parler ou alors
que moi je serai faussement accusés très
franchement je monterais au créneau et
j'irai pour défendre mon honneur et
c'est donc là il dit que c'est un choix
pour lui de ne pas avoir une parole
poste il réagira pas en fait après le
après le reportage de soirée face à face
à hewitt c'est un peu paradoxal parce
qu'en fait dans le reportage falla dans
l'interview en tout cas avec tous sens
il dit à un moment donné en fait je vais
me battre et il explique qu'il n'a pas
eu le temps finalement d'organiser sa
défense parce que d'une part il s'est
pas exactement les tenants et les
aboutissants mère quand il lui pose des
questions en rentrant un peu plus dedans
on a l'impression que finalement il sait
il connaît les accusations et connaît
les victimes en fait dont on parle donc
c'est un peu c'est un peu étrange s'est
positionné mais certaines qui va éviter
ce qui va s'exprimera clôturé avec un
dernier extrait c'est celui là qui a
fait énormément parler même il s'est
défendu en disant qu'il avait un
physique voilà il a glissé sur mon
physique très ingrat et que donc seul la
contrainte me permet de vivre des
histoires d'amour voilà mais non donc
les lieux où je n'ai jamais séduit par
contre vous ne voulez pas répondre
précisément aux questions concernant
cette affaire et il vous me posez la
question je vous dis non non non vous
n'avez pas choisi entre guillemets non
non vous ne l'avez pas forcé à venir
seul nom là bas et je vous dis très
clairement non il ne s'est rien passé
lorsqu'il était chez vous assis il s'est
passé quelque chose mais dans l'ain
consentement et une harmonie classique
d'une histoire sans lendemain alors bien
arnaud rien pas vrai mais cet humour est
obscène à ce moment là et les
changements techniques les désertions 7
pardonnez moi c'est surtout fois parce
qu'il a vécu avec une jeune femme qui
était la marraine de mon fils donc je
les ai beaucoup vu à une époque et
c'était un séducteur et plaisanciers le
pouvoir vous aimez les lives of heroes
hibon sous la contrainte mais c'est une
très bonne aide et séducteur c'est pas
moi el attar isabelle un séducteur c'est
pas prédateurs et est ce que j'ai dit
prédateur connu en tant que mécanisme
très décriée dans la race mère si oui ou
non merci merci
agirait en fait l'homme j'étais un peu
déçu par rapport à briscous ans c'est à
dire il évoque cette histoire de une
jeune stagiaire qui est dans une agence
pour être photographe c'est nicolas
hulot qui l'a choisie elle elle dit je
ne veux pas y aller seul je suis pas
assez expérimenté nicolas hulot dit mais
moi je veux qu'elle vienne seule et donc
nicolas hulot dit oui d'accord on a eu
un rapport sexuel mais c'était consenti
et bruce toussaint ne raconte pas la
chute de cette histoire c'est que cette
jeune fille rentre à l'agencé dit je
n'aurai plus jamais faire ça de savoir
que même si c'était un rapport consenti
mais décevant en quoi que ce soit on ne
change pas sa trajectoire
professionnelle pour ça que c'est à dire
que ont vite on parle toujours des
hommes accusés dont on aurait brisé les
carrières etc mais dans l'invisibilité
il ya des milliers de femmes qui
changent leurs trajectoires de vie leur
projet de vie pour suite à des violences
sexuelles et en se disant qu'ils n'ont
pas la force ni le rapport de forces
pour lutter contre sa relation et donc
il aurait fallu quand même raconté cette
chute en disant que suite à ce reportage
et bah cette femme a décidé que plus
jamais de travailler en agence en tant
qu au fond